it has been a very long night and day
here at the David Pakman show one
bleeding into the next you have no idea
what we've been dealing with since about
9:00 p.m. last night
until very late this morning I'm sort of
in disbelief that this is going on but I
am going to report to you today uh that
our a coverage of last night's
Democratic presidential debate on CBS
was shut down midstream jeopardizing our
entire twitch account and the revenue
that comes with it but the details here
are what is sickening and this is way
bigger than the David Pakman show the
stream that we were running yesterday of
the debate with our commentary and your
participation was cut either by
high-priced consultants hired by CBS CBS
to shut down independent media or by
some kind of right-wing troll group
posing as representatives of CBS now
this may sound confusing and it is and
I'm going to try to explain it to you as
clearly as I can because so much of this
information is still developing we're in
the middle of an investigation we are
engaging lawyers and as you can imagine
this is not what I want to be dealing
with in the middle of one of the most
important elections in our history but
this is how they win by making me have
to deal with this stuff so sit down and
get a load of this one as many of you
know we do our debate coverage on Twitch
where we've built a nice following of
close to 30,000 viewers it's not 810,000
like we have on youtube but we have a
growing and steady base of close to
30,000 followers on twitch yesterday
during the debate about halfway through
our stream which at the time had close
to 6,000 live viewers a nice debate for
us we had a lot of great audience
participation it was a great alternative
to the disastrous moderation that was
being provided by CBS our stream was
shut down and I was notified that we had
received a copyright strike these
copyright strikes do not expire on
twitch and that means that we are now
permanently one strike away
losing our twitch account forever the
whole point of building up twitch for
the last eight months was that the
streaming on YouTube had become too
risky because YouTube is already in the
pocket of so many of the large media
companies and they can shut us down any
time at the press of a button so we
started building up an audience on
Twitch and it became a nice source of
revenue for us so I get a message and it
says you've received a copyright
takedown for your stream of the CBS
debate now my initial assumption was of
course CBS started striking people doing
commentary on the debate that they were
broadcasting but upon further inspection
it looks like my stream Sam Cedars
stream the surf stream trihex is stream
and a whole bunch of others they were
taken down not by CBS but by a shadowy
organization called praxis political
legal if I look at the email I received
it says it was actually praxis political
legal who took down my stream on CBS's
behalf now this is already very odd
because a lot of the companies as large
as CBS they have an internal legal and
copyright team that handles this stuff
they don't hire someone else but when
they do they hire someone that you would
be able to sort of find information
about and that's where this gets even
weirder Praxis political legal lists a
contact email in the copyright takedown
that they sent me that email is legal at
praxis Polpette practice pol calm so I
immediately emailed that address to see
what's going on and to explain what we
were doing and that you know we want to
have this strike removed the email
address does not exist practice
political legal lists an email address
where when you email them you get a
bounce back that says address not found
so now it's starting to get really weird
praxis political legal files a copyright
takedown for CBS their contact email
does not even exist
so then I said well let's find the web
site for practice political legal when
you go to their web site they claim to
provide political
salting and legal services but they
provide almost no information whatsoever
about who they are and in fact they
don't even have their own website they
use one of these cheap single page
placeholder websites by a company called
card with two R's CA RR D it's like a
company that has a website that is
company named blog spot.com very weird
we aren't able to find any real evidence
that this company exists at least under
this name so we have two possibilities
here and they're both really bad
possibility number one is sometimes
these hatchet job political
consultancies they deliberately maintain
almost no internet presence specifically
because they focus on doing things that
they don't necessarily want to be known
for like shutting down left-wing
streamers commenting on a debate so it's
possible that it's a real company that
CBS really did hire them and that's sick
that if that's what's going on the other
possibility is because CBS has not in
the past shut down independent media
streams of debates and because companies
the size of CBS again often handle
copyright stuff internally not by hiring
out the other possibility is that this
company is not really representing CBS
that they have fraudulently claimed to
twitch to be representatives of CBS in
order to shut down streams like mine and
so many others on Twitch so either way
this is a crisis because first of all no
corporation should have a monopoly on
the platform that people can view a
debate that is being used to decide who
is going to represent the Democratic
Party in the general election and who is
going to be president ultimately if they
are going to defeat Donald Trump I've
said it before it's disgusting that one
can monopolize something that is in the
public interest or supposed to be anyway
when the moderation is good like a
debate it's disgusting but if it turns
out that this is a fraudulent group
claiming to represent CBS and they're
just lying about who they are then
twitch has a real problem here the
contact email for this practice
political
doesn't even exist how did twitch even
set them up as a an arbiter of copyright
takes down take down so what they do in
order to shut streams like ours down if
indeed they are fakes is falsely
represent themselves to twitch as agents
of CBS that's an issue if that's the
case that twitch needs to deal with in
YouTube as well needs to deal with
immediately now in the meantime we've
had to obtain legal representation
because our twitch account now is at
risk
one more bogus claim and our entire
twitch account is shut down forever okay
so I hate that this is what's going on
but I think we have to fight it with
legal services and that's not cheap we
could do the minimum which is like I
just don't do any more debate streams
and they win maybe we have to do that I
don't want to do that okay but if we get
one more strike on Twitch we're done
like that's it our account is done for
good or we can get really involved fight
it I want to do that get a lawyer try to
get these strikes removed and figure out
who is behind this company so grab a
membership if this bothers you if you
believe that this is what we need to be
fighting against at a time that is so
crucial for our democracy where we are
trying to decide who is going to fight
against Donald Trump this information
propaganda all of this stuff is
happening
grab a membership at join pakman.com ok
I just I can't believe that I spent the
better part of the overnight dealing
with this but it's where we are and
we've got to fight it so the coupon code
2020 now I don't care if you discount
your membership or not we just we
anything helps it does join pakman.com
you can sign up in under a minute
we're also on patreon patreon.com slash
david pakman show speaking to lawyers
again this afternoon I will update you
sometime later this week